Traduttore: SAMANTHA RAGAZZO
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Qual è la vostra prima reazione,
davanti a un’immagine come questa?
Paura, probabilmente:
invece il leone sta solo sbadigliando,
non c’era da aver paura.
Però la reazione è giusta,
e il nostro cervello si è evoluto
in modo da riconoscere velocemente
il pericolo, per poterci difendere.
Quali sono i pericoli che percepiamo,
nella nostra vita quotidiana?
Non so se vi riconoscete
in questa indagine:
però sembra che abbiamo molta paura
degli attacchi terroristici,
degli incidenti aerei,
ne abbiamo un po’ meno
del riscaldamento globale
e dell’elettrosmog,
e decisamente meno del cancro
e degli incidenti d’auto.
Però, se andiamo a vedere
i dati statistici
che stanno dietro al pericolo
reale di questi eventi,
vediamo che la realtà è molto diversa.
Il cervello umano non è adatto
a processare dati statistici,
a processare grandi quantità di dati.
Le macchine ci battono, lo sappiamo:
ci hanno battuto a GO,
ci hanno battuto a scacchi,
la chiamiamo "Intelligenza Artificiale".
E non è neanche una novità,
perché fece scalpore negli anni ’90
il fatto che un computer,
si chiamava Deep Blue,
potesse giocare a scacchi
contro l’allora campione del mondo.
E vinse: vinse anche nel ’97.
E perché vinse?
Secondo il giornale dell’epoca,
la macchina era stata migliorata
e riusciva a esaminare, addirittura,
200 milioni di posizioni al secondo.
Quindi riesce a fare una grande quantità
di calcoli in poco tempo,
che un cervello umano
non riuscirebbe mai a fare.
Però, se guardiamo poi
l’immagine completa,
troviamo una persona seduta
vicino a Deep Blue.
Sapete perché?
Serve solo a spostare
le pedine sulla scacchiera.
Quindi è un compito
di coordinazione senso-motoria
che per la persona evidentemente è banale
ma per la macchina è molto più difficile
di giocare a scacchi.
E in effetti, nel nostro cervello
il ragionamento logico,
questo tipo di capacità,
si sono evolute recentemente
in termini evoluzionistici;
mentre è ben più radicata
la coordinazione senso-motoria,
cioè quello che serve
per vivere nel mondo reale,
per cacciare, per sfuggire
ai predatori, per sopravvivere.
E questa è una sfida
molto più difficile, per le macchine:
anche più interessante,
perché potremmo costruire, forse,
macchine più utili;
e in effetti, la sfida attuale
dell’intelligenza artificiale
e della robotica
è il gioco del calcio.
Nel 2050, una squadra di calcio
di robot umanoidi autonomi
giocherà contro la nazionale
che in quell'anno si sarà aggiudicata
i campionati mondiali.
Ora, in questo i robot
ancora non ci hanno battuto:
tuttavia abbiamo paura dei robot.
Abbiamo paura che ci sostituiscano,
abbiamo pura che prendano
i nostri posti di lavoro,
abbiamo paura dei robot
che non ci sono ancora
e che invece dovremmo sperare di avere,
a fare certi lavori che per l’uomo
sono troppo faticosi, pericolosi,
questi sì.
E perché non ci sono i robot?
Perché i robot, che funzionano
così bene nelle fabbriche,
ancora non riescono
a svolgere questi lavori?
E perché invece gli esseri viventi sì?
Allora, proviamo a capire
quali trucchi ha trovato la natura
per far funzionare sistemi complessi
come un essere umano,
o un qualsiasi altro essere vivente,
in un mondo complesso.
Il trucco della natura
non è cercare di processare
tanti dati sempre più rapidamente;
il trucco della natura
è ridurre in maniera intelligente
la quantità di dati da processare.
Nel mio istituto, abbiamo studiato
un animale un po’ particolare,
che non fa pensare subito
alla robotica: il polpo comune.
È solo un mollusco,
ma riesce a fare cose strabilianti
con un corpo complesso
in un ambiente complesso.
Ha incredibili capacità di manipolazione,
ma anche di locomozione;
e questo è interessante per la robotica,
perché i robot non camminano sott’acqua.
Normalmente non è molto efficiente,
camminare sott'acqua;
ma il polpo lo fa.
E allora, studiando il polpo,
abbiamo cercato di capire
qual è il principio.
Che si basa sul fatto che il suo corpo
è completamente morbido,
il suo braccio si può
allungare e accorciare,
e può rimanere, come vedete,
anche sollevato dal fondale,
e ridurre l’attrito.
E abbiamo verificato questo principio
su un prototipo molto semplice
da far funzionare.
Però è costruendo un modello matematico
che spieghi questo principio
che si può progettare un robot
con forme e dimensioni diverse.
Come il robot che avete visto, Silver,
che per il National Geographic
ha fatto una missione
su un relitto all’isola d’Elba,
dimostrando non solo
come cammina sott’acqua,
ma anche come riesce a stare
completamente fermo
con un dispendio energetico
molto, molto basso.
Nel progetto Blue Resolution,
la sua evoluzione, "Silver 2",
aggiunge alcuni principi
studiati nel granchio
e va a esplorare i fondali
raccogliendo dei campioni di sedimento
per misurare poi la presenza eventuale
di micro-plastiche.
Quindi, cosa ci ha insegnato il polpo?
Ci ha insegnato a camminare sott’acqua;
ma ci ha anche fatto capire
come possiamo studiare gli esseri viventi
per costruire dei robot utili.
Ora, tutto questo è avvenuto in Italia;
ma com’è messa l’Italia nella robotica?
Qual è la vostra percezione?
Nella ricerca, siamo messi molto bene:
La ricerca si misura
in numero di articoli scientifici,
e questo ci posiziona
al sesto posto nel mondo,
quindi un’ottima posizione,
per un paese relativamente piccolo.
E terzi in Europa.
Ma abbiamo anche una bellissima tradizione
di aziende di robotica industriale,
e più recentemente
di robotica di servizio.
E anche in questo caso,
nella classifica mondiale siamo decimi,
in Europa siamo quarti:
è un buon posizionamento.
Poi pensiamo sempre che, però,
queste startup piccole
ad altissima tecnologia,
che poi diventano molto ricche,
nascono in America
e si sviluppano in America:
è vero, verissimo.
Però, nel settore della robotica
l'Europa è competitiva
e supera anche un pochino gli Stati Uniti.
E in questo scenario, l'Italia
ha una bellissima ottava posizione.
Però l'Italia ha molto più di questo,
non ha soltanto la tecnologia.
Il futuro della robotica, oggi,
è un'impresa multidisciplinare.
Dobbiamo ripensare ai modelli economici
per poter utilizzare i robot
nel mondo del lavoro,
anziché temerli;
dobbiamo immaginare e studiare
i modelli sociali del futuro,
anziché farceli imporre dalla tecnologia;
dobbiamo disegnare un contesto normativo
per l'introduzione dei robot nella società
e naturalmente garantire
il rispetto di principi etici.
E l'Italia è il miglior posto
per fare questo,
non solo perché abbiamo la tecnologia
e abbiamo l'industria,
ma perché abbiamo una tradizione culturale
che è profondamente radicata
nelle scienze umane.
E quindi l'Italia è il posto giusto
per progettare, oggi,
i robot sostenibili di domani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)